les gens sont venus nombreux ils
tenaient à se faire entendre en
consultation publique sur le tout
nouveau programme qui doit remplacer
celui d'immersion française dans les
écoles anglophones
ce que vous proposez
le ministre de l'Éducation bureau gun
c'est donc assis et pendant deux heures
il a écouté des parents des
grands-parents des enseignants et des
retraités du milieu scolaire dénoncer
l'abolition de l'immersion française
réduire l'enseignement du français de
50% ne va pas améliorer le Français a
dit ce père de famille exaspérée c'est
ridicule
le gouvernement de blending ne veut plus
de l'immersion française parce qu'il
n'est pas enseigné à tous les élèves
anglophones il souhaite donc un nouveau
programme pour tous mais qui offrira
beaucoup moins d'heures d'enseignements
du français que l'immersion
le Premier ministre blendings s'est déjà
mis à dos de nombreux francophones à la
suite de décision impopulaire qu'il a
prise dans des dossiers linguistiques et
voilà maintenant que les critiques
fusent de communauté anglophones là où
se trouve sa base électorale
la député conservatrice Andrea Anderson
message demande à son gouvernement de
freiner sa réforme la cote de popularité
du Premier ministre Kings est déjà sur
une pente descendante selon des sondages
et le dossier de l'immersion n'est pas
selon le politologue il faut que je te
demande beaucoup pourquoi qu'on se tient
toujours derrière ce premier ministre de
notre partie c'est une lui qui va nous
guider dans la prochaine élections pour
gagner c'est quoi ton but voiture
le ministre de l'éducation n'a répondu à
aucune question mais il a semblé moins
rigide sur des changements à venir aux
journalistes il a laissé entendre qu'il
pourrait peut-être modifier le plan il
faut prendre tout ce qu'on avait entendu
tout est renseignements qu'on a reçu
puis à ce point alors il faut qu'on
fasse une décision il a décision viendra
d'ici le début du printemps ici Michel
Bridou Radio-Canada